[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to let's
be honest if you took Pixar out the
equation Disney would still be putting
out some damn good CGI films from
tangled to wreck-it Ralph to frozen -
Moana
Disney has been making smash after smash
winning over both audiences and critics
some of them are even among the
highest-grossing movies of all time
it's amazing the quality of films
they're pushing out God did it not start
that way
being Disney's second computer anime a
film without Pixar Chicken Little is
among one of the most awkward
uncomfortable mean-spirited movies
they've ever made and don't get me wrong
I love mean-spirited Disney whether it
be their villains creepy imagery or
whatever Christ this is but that's not
what Chicken Little is it's supposed to
be bright colorful enough beat but
instead it's UE disturbing and as upbeat
as an animated series I'm a good son how
does such a thriving CG Empire hatch
from such an ugly rotten egg well we're
here to take an unfortunate look let's
see why our IQs are falling with Chicken
Little
so the money is so unclear with its tone
that it actually has three false starts
once upon a time how many times have
y'all heard that's the beginners story
no I don't think so it sounds familiar
doesn't it oh no no not the book how
many have seen opening the book before
you know naming cliches surprisingly
doesn't make you above them you have to
actually do something with them it's
like if I start off a movie with this
movie starts in a store know a house
know a bar sorry
sometimes I type my post-it notes into
the script so they decide to go with I
guess no intro as we just cut the
chicken little telling everybody to run
for cover
waiting to some already confusing jokes
I guess what's supposed to be funny as
rabbits have a lot of kids how they all
fit into one stroller is at least in
abstractly forced joke how's this for
world building a universe comprised
entirely of animals is watching Indiana
Jones this universe is as coherent as a
VR chat room nothing is established but
hey a giant water tower knocks out cars
honking Old MacDonald
get it I don't as if all of this wasn't
aggressively nonsensical enough keep in
mind we're not even two minutes in
nothing is properly established except
zootopia's direct-to-dvd sequel clearly
needed 10 more rewrites don't tell me
the main character's name I was happy in
this anarchy of confusion this is 12
year old Chicken Little voiced by
30-year old Zach Braff I know it's a
piece of the sky somewhere that matches
as well as dr. claw voicing Ariel says
the sky is falling but everyone thinks
he confused it for an acorn
it doesn't help either they start saying
gibberish for never any established
reason that is backwards I still stand
by Garden State fool so the town makes a
movie about him as towns do that's just
one year later and littles father voiced
by Gary Marshall constantly reminds him
of his failure would be better for you
just to lay low don't call attention to
yourself right yes it's it's like a game
a game of hide-and-seek except the goal
is never to be found ever the important
thing is you feel no love from me like
my audiences reaction to the other
system are we don't make eye contact
okay he rung a bell not to capitate a
student book burnings have more
tolerance than this after discovering
even traffic won't stop for him he makes
it to class where Patrick Stewart plays
his greatest role since a pile of shit
as the teacher who reads off the
students names it just happened to be
descriptive phrases Foxy Loxy present
pretty functional runt of the litter
fish-out-of-water happy man
[Music]
hello hello this is the 1950s we'd like
our cartoon sound effect at something
ugly back I'm sorry I have no control
over that oh well who does they suppose
the people who made this movie but they
made it in 2005 right yeah
when they have moved on to newer
material by then well what would think
for Disney Oh God
Disney used that joke they must be in
Arad well they will be for a while but
believe it or not they do pull out why
am I still going with this joke has
anyone noticed by the way the animation
moves like a choppy cut scene from a
PlayStation 2 game everyone is either
spastic or has more Mali in them than
the movie toast split into two teams
popular versus unpopular move over
George Orwell someone else has beaten
you for best commentary cold shell and
popular shooting we review safety
guidelines sure hit the pig kids why do
I feel like this world is one step away
from man in the high castle
just do it Fisher's doing
please copyright money on a song for a
joke that blows Chicken Little tells
Ugly Duckling played by Joe Kuzak that
he wants to do something great to get
everyone's mind off the goof up they
made a year ago and make his dad proud
again but she doesn't think it's a good
idea the nut needs to be cracked open
I am smashed bits of emotion flying
everywhere anger frustration denial fear
you see what I'm saying
character over explains something that
nobody understands classic outdated
comedy now comes the part where we throw
our heads back and laugh ready no
there's a whole section about it in this
month's modern hours she says he needs
closure with his father but
fish-out-of-water uses the cars that
fall out of her magazine to build a
skyscraper
I thank this movie for allowing me to
reference loaded weapon one by asking
the question you stole from loaded
weapon one little tells the bullies to
stop picking on them but he's flung
against the window
adding to the good cheer this film has
to offer I guess this is done while the
teacher is gone but really wouldn't it
be encouraged while the teacher was
there this world is pretty sick he sets
off the fire alarm though of course
getting blamed leading to his father
called to the principal's office
now look buck you were buck Ace cluck
our school baseball star your kid he's
nothing like you at all
that in no way connects to anything but
it's good to know the principal's as big
a dick in this world as anyone else
little decides to sign up for the
baseball team to try and make his dad
proud when he's constantly benched until
his big break up next Chicken Little
you're gonna fail and we don't love you
surprisingly though he makes a hit
immediately winning over the town's
bottomless pit of shallow attention even
his asshole dad congratulate his
athletic achievement with
passive-aggressive praise I guess that
puts the whole sky is fully incident
behind his words bro my love for you was
like a grocery store staff constantly
shifting depending on convenience but
things change when apparently a piece of
the sky falls but he keeps it a secret
so people don't mock him again so he
calls ugly duckling and runt of the
litter who are singing beautifully dated
karaoke if you wanna be my
foot size joke in frozen gets a PG but
singing about the qualifications of
being someone's lover every toddler
should see that or how about this nugget
of family okayness remember when that
icy blue stuff fell from the sky and he
just turned out to be frozen pee from a
jet airplane it's frozen pee I love my
kids films to have towns getting pissed
on I really need more of that and Winnie
the Pooh he shows them the device but it
accidentally sucks up fish out of water
and they go to save him
what was that about oh it's amazing how
none of this is like the original source
material at all I hope this doesn't
become a thing
[Applause]
[Music]
the kids go into the alien ship where
they find fish out of water as well as
apparently an evil plan to destroy the
earth either that or they're just
marking off places they've already been
I cross off a day on my calendar I
didn't destroy the day the aliens find
the kids though and try to attack gee I
wonder if a crowd circle joke is coming
up great just throw a door at them in a
glass of water and they'll be P for life
Chicken Little rings the bell alerting
the town but of course the aliens go
away and no one believes him again
it's the Acorn thing all over again yeah
there's no story here well at least we
can sell the video the chickens gone
wild the fact that there's a show called
chickens gone wild with the fact that a
little boy qualifies to be in it mommy
take away your Streisand collection okay
can the remainder of this review just be
me speculating what kind of animal
Streisand is in this world I'm gonna say
anteater of course he looks to his dad
for support who completely turns his
back on him yet again I I'm really sorry
about this everyone looks like this is
just a big crazy misunderstanding
they designed him with two apple seeds
for eyes it's amazing he sees anything
at all one of the aliens is left behind
though and I do have to give credit that
they could have gone with just a generic
alien design but they do get creative by
putting Rainbow Brite shoes on troll
here let's be house Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull would have been a little
better if this was the alien thus he
ends up befriending little his name is
Kirby they left him behind
Vader's huge father oh come on Lucas
films are the only human movies we get
out here how aren't we talking about the
more but the sky breaks apart for all
the town to see and the aliens start
invading looking for their kid we gotta
go no wait dad I gotta tell you
something what what I know I know you
were right alien invasion I see that now
look up okay for the amount of asshole
eNOS we've been putting up with that's
not enough we need like the entire town
to bow down to him like Return of the
King
you keep getting copyrights for other
songs how about how a source scored from
that moment forget it
you wouldn't believe me anyway son son
forget it buck it's chicken town where
they play chickens gone wild seriously
what was that
well obviously ripping off Spielberg's
War of the Worlds though apparently not
obvious enough as they literally have to
tell you and this isn't a parody of the
matrix what catches up to Chicken Little
and they try to work things out you're
never there for me I mean you were you
were there when I won the B game but now
what I thought this guy fell your mom
she was you know she was always good
with stuff like this
I'll never forget the day she never came
back from Panda Express but you need to
know that I love you and I'm sorry if I
ever made you feel like that was
something you had to earn no I mean
granted any love I've shown for you has
clearly been done to earning it but
that's not what I know that's what I
intended oh and he kisses ugly duckling
because their relationship was so
special they decide to spring it on you
at this very moment
that's closure now if only you showed
how it started by the way for the amount
of aliens looking for this kid how can
they not Spock Conan O'Brien's pubic
hair running through this gray
colourless city even when they do find
him they don't turn him over I think
it's a safe bet any of these ships will
get him to his parents but they're
anything like chicken littles dad I'm
just assuming they disowned him already
they make it to the roof and try to get
the alien to the literal mothership but
they get beamed up and talk to the
aliens dad release the child
I recognize that number that means it's
funny it'd be nice if there was some
connection to that zip code that gave it
some relevance but just be recognizing
it is enough writing words are hard but
the Sun comes in to save them and
returns the town - how did we want to
put it a normal terrible old cells that
is except for Foxy Loxy who seems to
have lost her bully tomboy ways way to
put her back the way she was Oh little
girl her parents raised is dead but show
tunes darling look at the time we better
get a move on I guess I shouldn't be
shocked that Disney merchandising has
made it to plan it's off than that but
having Mickey with the third eye isn't
that kind of like alien blackface I like
to see the movie they make about you now
I just hope they stay true to what
really happened loss on these people are
from Hollywood this iron is so thick
Tony Stark is making a suit out of it
the movies of course overblown
ridiculous and has no connection to the
original tale and the film version they
watch isn't that good either now you can
throw your head back and laugh I gotta
give credit to casting Adam West as
macho Chicken Little though it may be
the only funny scene in the movie the
sky is please call me ace and yet it's
still more accurate than the blindside
Chicken Little the dad and the audience
are happy with the movie though proving
this film's more all the facts and
deeper meaning don't mean shit as long
as you're satisfied for the moment
the credits roll with wonted foxy
singing a duet because that's really
funny you know because of all their
interactions that they had with each
other and now they're complete opposites
oh you know what the interactions like
this couple seconds and no we're goddamn
else Chicken Little
it's about relationships question mark
five explanation points yes this is not
only an unfunny film it's just kind of a
rotten film everyone is so needlessly
cruel and not in a fun way that the
world characters or environments then
better realize are defined maybe the
meaner jokes could have worked but it
just tosses you an awkward cruelty after
awkward cruelty yes there's a good
lesson about parents and kids listening
to each other but it's done with such
bland and/or unlikable characters that
it's hard to take reasonably and on top
of that it's just not the story it's
like if the tortoise and the hare had
aliens and the moral is never trust a
wolf in sheep's clothing it just doesn't
add up I hear a lot of people grew up
liking this and if that's the case I
can't follow the message is trying to
get across but as Disney films go this
is a spoiled egg worth passing I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and next week I better
get a better bird movie that's not based
on a phone app dick
[Music]
[Applause]
piggy-corn of all flat
hey I'm Doug Walker doing the charity
shout out and if you see this you
probably know what charity I'm doing
today it's the children's health fund
yeah I know you've seen that Red Nose
campaign here and there and it's for a
good reason the children's health fund
is committed to ensuring high quality
health care to America's most
disadvantaged children they achieved
this through expanding access to
comprehensive primary care reducing
health barriers to learning responding
to the needs of children impacted by
major public health crisis and improving
the health and well-being of children
through efficacy and public education
efforts over the years they've
replicated this approach across the
country today the national network
provides care through 24 innovative
pediatric care programs and affiliates
that serve children in poor rural and
urban communities across the country if
you look at their site in their YouTube
channel you can see just how hard they
work to make sure as many children as
possible get the care they need get your
red nose on and donate to an
organization working hard to help so
many
[Music]
you